good afternoon I'm Philip Khoury I'm
associate provost at MIT with
responsibility for the arts and I want
to welcome all of you to this public
presentation by Robert Lapage who is the
recipient of the 2012 Eugene McDermott
award in the arts at MIT
we're very pleased also to have with us
Peter Gelb the general manager of the
Metropolitan Opera we look forward to a
stimulating and lively dialogue about
technology and stagecraft and
storytelling before introducing our
distinguished guests let me say a few
words about the McDermott award which is
one of the most generous arts prizes in
the United States established in 1974 by
Margaret McDermott to honor her late
husband Eugene co-founder of Texas
Instruments the award recognizes
individuals whose artistic trajectory
and body of work indicate that they will
achieve the highest distinction in their
fields the award is considered an
investment in the recipients future
creative work rather than a prize for a
particular project or a lifetime of
achievement most of all however the
McDermott award reflects MIT s
commitment to risk-taking
problem-solving and connecting creative
minds across disciplines I want to
especially thank Mary McDermott cook
daughter of Margaret and Eugene
McDermott who is here this evening this
afternoon late evening in the front row
here she continues the great commitment
of her family to the Arts here at MIT in
their hometown dallas and in many many
other places mary delighted you're here
with us to help honor roberta posh
now recounting just a few aspects of
rubella Pasha's work will reveal why he
is such an ideal recipient of this award
the Pasha's multidisciplinary work
defies categorization as you will have
learned from the extraordinary array of
work in the timeline that was projected
as you entered this auditorium mr.
Lapage is equally talented as a
playwright actor film director and stage
director he and his production company
ex machina have toured numerous
productions internationally to critical
and popular acclaim from large multiple
part productions to one person plays
including the Anderson project recently
presented in Boston by arts Emerson he
has created two Cirque de Soleil
productions Kaah a resident show at MGM
Grand in Las Vegas and totem which will
be seen in Boston in June he has acted
in or directed numerous feature films he
staged directed to musical tours for
rock star Peter Gabriel who I just
learned was here at our Media Lab just
yesterday he has created spectacular
outdoor illuminations and architectural
projections in Quebec Harbor using the
surface of the Bunge grange grain
elevators as a giant screen spectacular
really and you will understand why the
Pasha's work resonates with the creative
values of the MIT community we at MIT
particularly admire his willingness to
cross disciplinary boundaries in the
pursuit of innovation the collaborative
enterprise that drives his creative
output his relentless experimentation
with new technologies in order to
reimagine for the 21st century the
ritual origins of multiple performances
on including of course opera which some
people would say is inherently the most
multidisciplinary of performance
performances on which brings me to our
second distinguished guest today Peter
Gelb since becoming general manager of
the Metropolitan Opera in 2006 Peter
Gelb has launched a host of initiatives
to revitalize the Met and to connect it
to a wider audience under his leadership
the company has recruited many of the
world's great theatre directors
including Robert Lapage he also
increased the annual number of new
productions secured more performances
from tops
and he launched the trailblazing Peabody
award-winning series of the met live in
HD which represents live performance
transmissions in movie theaters around
the world I'm interested to note then
much earlier in his career in 1978 Peter
Gelb was an assistant manager of the
Boston Symphony Orchestra so perhaps one
could say that his illustrious career
was launched right here in Boston in any
case he has won six Emmy Awards and
three Peabody Awards since then we owe
special thanks to mr. Gelb for being
here today since he must return to New
York immediately after this program in
order to make the curtain for a
performance tonight of Das Rheingold the
first opera in wagonette Wagner's
four-part their English Nibelungen
directed by Robert posh the four operas
in the cycle have been presented over
the last two seasons and are being
presented this month and in May as a
complete cycle for the first time now
Robert Lapage is first began directing
opera in 1993 and first collaborated
with the Metropolitan Opera in 2008 and
nine in that season when he directed
like dem ness Ziona Faust the damnation
of Faust back door Berlioz the Pasha's
production used an innovative
combination of virtual scenery
interactive video projections and aerial
acrobatics the dramatized the timeless
melodramatic plot of sin and redemption
his transformation of vogner's 16-hour
Ring cycle however is the most ambitious
production the Met has ever attempted
the four works in the cycle or operas
most challenging and transcendent epic
the Mets new production which premiered
between September 2010 and January 2012
uses a groundbreaking single set
comprised of 24 moveable planks which
together with computerized projections
form every mythic scene an action that
vogner imagined we at MIT appreciate the
ambition of this undertaking especially
the scale of imagination and the
technical complexity that the new
production entails and we appreciate the
risk-taking involved in
reconceptualizing a revered masterpiece
in this way including the controversy
that such bold moves
can and will generate productive
disruptions of norms are healthy and
necessary for innovation for they
generate new thinking and inventions for
the benefit of us all
that's very Lapage and it's very MIT -
we look forward now to hearing from
these two great creative minds about the
ring and other aspects of mr. Lapage as
diverse an expansive body of work ladies
and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming robear Lapage and Peter Gelb
not used to sitting in such a deep I
don't know what controversy you're
talking about
I'm Peter Gelb this is Roberta posh as
I'm sure you know I am very happy to be
here to have this conversation in front
of you with robear i it's true that my
career did begin in Boston but I haven't
been here much in recent years I mostly
stayed in contact by watching Yankee Red
Sox games but I won't go any further I
don't kind of like loading the Red Sox
women when they're sure well now when I
was appointed to the men at the end of
2004 I was determined to reconnect the
met to the cultural mainstream which is
not necessarily an easy thing to do with
an opera company with 128 or
129 year old history and that was in
recent decades not used to making much
much in the way of change but I was
determined that we had to change the
very essence and of what we put on the
stage and the way in which we connected
with our audiences both inside the Opera
House and outside the Opera House and I
sought the help of a number of leading
directors but the person who I helped I
saw it I think first was Revere Lapage
because I had known his work and and
I've known him for about 20 years and I
believed that the way to to change the
basic fabric of opera required bringing
in great creative minds and visionary
people with visionary ideas such as
Revere and there's no in fact there's no
director in the world that I know of
today who
deserves I think this prestigious award
more than Robair his visual visual
imagination and nakid at storytelling is
what sets him apart from all that not to
say there aren't other great great
directors who are visual who have great
visual imagination and are great
storytellers but robear's
has an individual voice that which is
remarkable in that it is also note two
projects of his seem to bear any direct
visual connection to each other each
thing he does which is very unusual I
think for directors each project that he
takes on really has a soul and a life an
artistic character of its own so I I
because of that and because of my
knowledge of robear's career I sort of
instinctively understood that it was he
who I had to go to to direct the immense
new Ring cycle which is because of its
scale and and sheer length of 16 hours
long four operas is the single even if
you don't approach it on the scale the
ro-bear approach to john it's it's the
largest undertaking any opera company
could possibly take take on the and
since I believe in in taking risks in
order to change the face of opera and
advance it I embraced and supported all
of robear's revolutionary technological
ideas for this ring even though
sometimes it seemed that my fate and the
and the fortunes of the Met were
swinging in the balance but
but for a new ring I would I would
rather gamble with robear than with
anybody else and in a few hours as
Philip mentioned a few hours from now
we're beginning of the first really
tightly scheduled Ring cycle of this new
production which is why I have to fly
back to New York Robair wisely is
staying behind but his work his work has
been done the last night in fact two
timed with the opening of the of our new
of our new wing cycles was the premiere
of a fascinating documentary film about
the making of this ring in which
documentary filmmaker Susan frumpkis
spent I guess about five years following
robear and his team and and because of
my long relationship with her and trust
in her I gave her can sort of complete
access to everything that went on at the
mint almost complete access and she the
film premiered at the Tribeca Film
Festival last night and will be shown in
movie theaters later on in fact next
month but I thought it would be
interesting just to get things rolling -
we have a lot of boo-bear has has
brought a lot of video of and his
colleagues have arranged for us to see a
lot of interesting examples of his work
but I thought just to give us a sense of
the scale and scope of this new ring
there's a taste of it
we would play this trailer for the movie
for the for this documentary which we're
gonna do so now if we could play the the
vogner dream trailer plays nothing
defines an opera house more than new
productions opera has to be constantly
renewing itself
Metropolitan Opera kicks off its new
season with the lavish production of
vogner's for Park Ring cycle it's the
most ambitious production the Met has
never mounted this is as big as it gets
for an opera company no new production
is more significant the story of the
ring is the creation and the destruction
of the world 16 hours of opera this is
an intense challenge for any director
draw their Lapage one of theatres great
visionaries we use state of the art
tools to present a really fresh new
avant-garde
crazy ring I went to Iceland digging
into the Icelandic nerve roots tectonic
sets breaking apart and separated shoots
Scandinavian myths
I love honour I'm afraid of what they're
gonna do with it though parts of it have
always been unstageable swimming
underwater walking over Rainbow Bridge
sliding and winged horses nobody has
gotten it perfectly right that's what
we're trying to do Deborah Voigt he'll
be singing Brunhilde for the very first
time there are only one or two or three
broomhilda's who can command the stage
of the match there are so many
challenging vocal passages it can be be
defining in her career it was so
daunting for such a time that I thought
are you out of your mind
it's a very emotional journey this one
have you seen those sets I'm a little
bit nervous about standing on it
see stop you were never in danger
everything was like I don't want to lose
my feet or whatever this is when the
real pros come out everything okay so
far so good
yeah always compared to you know being
kind of a Christopher Columbus I have to
convince a whole crew that you're not
gonna fall off the edge of the earth
that you are going to discover something
you know it's there you're getting there
this is what opera is like we want more
so it's uh that's just the tip of the
iceberg you could say that again the
silver bear why don't you I know that
you believe that the storytelling is
more important than anything else in
anything you stage and technology
obviously played a huge part in this
production and but maybe you can talk a
little bit about how you you know how
you harness the technology and why your
mind is the technology that you did
harness and you know the story of how
you came to this and yeah
well actually I've I've always been an
artist who who had problems really
defining himself you know I I'm a stage
director but I'm also an actor I'm also
a filmmaker and/or I'm all of the above
whatever but it's not important exactly
what I do for the ideas that I like
mingling with different people who work
in different disciplines and I think
that the Opera certainly will the stage
in general but let's say that the opera
more than theatre more than dance is is
a place is a great meeting point and
it's you know Varner spoke of the chasm
koontzville
he he dreamed of the gazhams comes back
which means the the together artistic
work which is a literal translation that
means the the meeting point the
gathering of all sorts of people from
different disciplines and and I really
believe that Opera is the great
multidisciplinary way of working way of
telling a story so of course it's I was
a question of finding the balance
between who tells what part of the story
and and what's redundant and what's over
over over stated and so I'm for me the
whole technological research or presence
in my work is just there as a tool to
merge these disciplines together I work
in a field
well I'm mainly a stage director from
the theater so that means I work a lot
in the live world
but I'm also interested by the recorded
word I like doing films once in a while
I like doing television stuff and and
and I think that in the 21st century
audiences are going to want something
more of theater and something more of
film and the qualities of theatre are
being more and more asked from from the
recorded medium which has become a kind
of you know of course you have the
intimacy in movies because of the close
ups and all that and the great sound but
you don't you don't have the liveness
the interaction with with film that you
have in theater and then vice versa with
the theater world you don't have the
sense of intimacy if you're in a 2000
seat room you're not as close to the
actors so how do how do you how do you
get all of the advantages of films so I
think that the way for these two worlds
that that are very very close cousins
because we're dealing with actors we're
dealing with writers with storytellers
and we're trying to convey the same
ideas the same emotions I think that the
more the technology is the same that
more that the lighting you use in film
and and the lighting that I use in on
stage is the same instruments or the the
data or the codes or any kind of
technology that is being used in both
worlds is common then there's a dialogue
then there's an openness and then I
believe that the 21st century it was
probably will probably be the scene of
some eighth form of Arts which will be a
great meeting point of all of those
disciplines and and of course we would
this is one attempt opera the upper
world is a great place to try that it's
full of traps and obstacles and but as
we say in in in Buddhism your obstacles
are your friends so of course I've made
a lot of friends
of this experience but and but I believe
in that really I really believe that I
still believe in the stage I still
believe in and people gathering in the
same room seeing artists taking risks
because it's a very very risky saying
and certainly opera is a sport and
actually but I find remarkable in your
way of presenting it in the HD
transmissions it is like an exciting
hockey game or an exciting a football
game because you have the the singers
concentrating and you know stepping on
stage singing their their heart outs and
then as soon as they walk off you catch
them and you say so how was it you know
I know that so it's it's a it's a bit
crazy but for some reason our pro lends
itself to that because it's a
larger-than-life effort it's a
larger-than-life way of telling a story
and and and I think it's I really truly
still believe in in opera and its
potential it's just been ignored a bit
or it's it's been it's it hasn't been as
accessible let's say to to everybody as
in in the past century as it should have
been but it used to be in the nineteen
seventy I mean some of the problems or
the length of operas and also and the
languages that you have to read
subtitles for you to sort of but like
going to a foreign film or something you
have to be able to go over yeah will be
willing to accept absolutely yeah
there's a lot of conventions but that's
the thing that I find extraordinary
about these G transmissions from my
hometown in Quebec City
the rooms are filled with people who've
never been to the Opera before you see
grandfathers and their children
explaining the story of course it's in
German with English sure titles and
their french-speaking people I mean of
course but there's there's a passion
there's a mystery there there's there
something that that seems to attract
them to so I think III think there's a
lot of Hope in this the but getting
getting to the essence of the ring when
you I mean I think it's since this is
probably the single biggest project I
guess
undertaken as well as I have at the met
can you you know there has been some as
Phillip mentioned some controversy
around it which seems to be mostly out
of your choice - even though you're
using the most modern technological
means to tell the story that vogner
wrote as opposed to doing it in some
sort of more abstract metaphorical yeah
well there's something I mean very few
people know this is that I hope Vanner
fans or opera fans will eventually have
the chance to read the whole score and
the whole libretto of the ring but it is
it reads like a film script and burners
I mean most people know the story of the
ring but you want to put myself through
that exercise but but but we Intel
together know but the thing is reason
why I say it reads like a film scripts
because what what Vanner asks of the
stage designer and and and lighting
designer and the director what what he
asks of us is a movie in and at a time
were filmed exact when when vogner is as
as was pointed out in this documentary
when vogner create you know created the
ring he built this theater to put it on
and by roid and then produced it but was
very unhappy with the results of course
because he couldn't he had no he didn't
have the technological the technical
examiners who represent a story this
impossible story that he had he had it
just means that he what he was a
Freudian before Freud he was cinematic
before cinema so you know that's the
great genius of
and so that's one of the reasons why you
decided to absolutely and to put myself
at the service of that of these demands
so of course there's a lot of people who
think that there's no personal vision of
the ring but for me my my it's my
entrance into the veterinarian world I I
I have I have a front of me a monument
it's much bigger than myself and and and
I I want to learn from it so I tried to
be as faithful to the story as possible
and in every detail and see how in this
day and age if we do have the technology
to do accomplish many many miracles how
can we actually illustrate these things
and sometimes people have been very
critical of some elements that I've
staged were that were actually demands
from that writer weight the public loves
loves it and the proof of that is in
their reaction in inside the Opera House
you know we have some video examples of
you know some of the things that you did
which vogner as you said demanded or
asked for various actions to be depicted
that opera houses when they produced the
ring never do because they don't have
the scenery or the wherewithal to do to
do it so you with this machine that you
and your designers created invented set
out from the beginning to be able to
realize all these scenic ideas of Honor
that typically are heard musically but
never actually represented on these days
so do you want to is there one you
wanted well maybe there's there one of
the first sex services maybe the descent
down into to Valhalla initially from to
nibble hang actually there is a huge
chunk of music where there's a
suggestion but by Wagner where we
actually see vote on as well just so
vote vote on the king of the Gods has
reneged on his deal with the Giants who
built his new castle and he realized as
though that he's in a lot of trouble and
he to get out of it to get out of it he
and his aid to Kampala go the god of
fire decides to go down into the
underworld where Nibelheim
where albick the the dwarf has who was
previously in the beginning of the opera
has stolen the gold from the Rhine which
sets off this whole and had a closing
chain of events there albergue is down
in in Nibelheim
with his fellow dwarves making more
treasure and planning for an assault on
the on the gods and the powers above so
so vote on goes down there with logos
yeah the normal normally this is not
seen a curtain comes in and you hear the
music and the next you're supposed to
imagine moves to imagine of course if
you know the libretto and if you know
the story so maybe we could look at an
excerpt of course we'll be doing this a
bit accelerate because extras can be a
bit long ish but we might speed it up on
the way so you can get to appreciate all
of it although this one might read wreak
havoc yeah
so in fact they they eventually they
eventually get there yeah they've
actually given actually maybe to give
you a sense of they of the scope we
could watch another excerpt which is the
extra but the end of the Vancouver when
volton puts his his daughter Brunhilde
to sleep
gives him maybe a better scope of what
the whole project was and we should
point out this is one of the maybe the
first opera in certainly the first opera
in history the Met to use utilize stunt
doubles but some of the stunts have
didn't actually perform sometimes by
some of the performers some of the those
are do a crevasse yeah absolutely but no
we don't normally send our singers but
it happened it happened at times that
some singers you want to get rid of it
some singers would show up and look at
the stunt and say I can I can do that
it's a well not really sure but actually
you actually got to do it so maybe we
could look at me that another extra
bright away just to give you a sense of
the scope of the
so what you've seen basically is the end
of bad kula and second the second of the
second ultra and so what was very
challenging for us is to try to create a
stage that has something very
traditional about it because it's
actually 24 planks and and when it
starts it's in a rake position so it
looks like a traditional opera house
rate raked floor and it all looks very
very normal but then eventually when it
starts with with the the beginning of
the Rhine golden and we tried to
normally it's the music of the Rhine so
we the plank starts rocking and the
eventually formed become very very
sensuous water and eventually evolved
into all sorts of different locations
and and of course as the story evolves
and becomes illustrates many many many
things so what it was inspired by
basically was the the idea that some of
those well most of the ring comes from
the Icelandic eras and the headers are
pretty much like the kind of a Bible in
Indian Icelandic and in Viking culture
so Silvana we keep forgetting that
Varner actually borrowed those heroes
and these stories and to create the
story of the Ring and because of that
and I was I'd been to Iceland a few
times and was struck how in went went
because I in a past life I was
interested in geography and geology and
it was all into tectonic plates and the
movement of continents and and volcanic
activity and all that did a show I
didn't even know a show called tectonic
plates and Iceland is that a few been
toys done before but it's a tiny island
of a country that's sitting in the
middle of the ridge where actually the
world is America and Europe are kind of
separating and even the countries
separating it each year there's a fault
and that opens 6 centimeters each year
so it's a it's a it's a moving place
that the ground is a moving
it's not a stable place and it has all
sorts of eruptions and all sorts of
states and all that and when you you
visit Iceland you you have a very
different take on the ring because you
go oh I can understand somebody a
culture living here and imagining how
all elements manifest themselves and how
they do believe that there is a God of
fire and a god of thunder and a God of
this and I got of that so I wanted to
create something that would be tectonic
in a certain way there was some kind of
where the ground would be very stable
which was very alarming for a lot of
seniors because they will you're walking
on something that moves all the time
that the singer the the the what we just
saw the end of ocular was the singer
Bryn Terfel whose vote on the ruler of
the gods in the foreground and he's just
sentenced his daughter Brunhilde for
disobeying him to an endless sleep
surrounded by fire and a cup of months
on top of the mountain but that actual
singer who plays Brunhilde had exited
and this resist by her stunt imw a party
tip oh yeah through the operatic
equivalent of the piano drop
the soprano drop so yeah what else
should we talk about the ring do you
want to you want to talk about the bit
of about the creation of the of this of
the design of the sets or you have some
animation that we may be yeah we have
just to understand about how the premise
of all this we have a clip of the the
set designer California who's a set
designer was actually an amazing stage
engineer I've been working with him in
subdue soleil a lot and doing some other
theatrical creations actually do work
actually as many do and we're gonna get
to that in a little while but you're
unlike many most directors have one team
they were you work with many teams many
different directors I many different
designers yes absolutely yeah of course
Cal is probably what was for a long time
the principle one because I was asked to
have always interested to do these big
big shows and all that and Cal has his
his back is strong enough to actually
take on these projects so maybe we could
show some of his 3d animations of the
set so you'd understand a bit and
actually we could speed up right yeah
this we could speed up yeah it's
actually so so this is the princess when
we were saying that it starts with the
this is the beginning whether the the
Rhine maidens come out and of course
they're suspended by the set and this
was created in two thousand seven or
eight yeah yeah yeah absolutely so
there's a kind of a sped-up version so
was the Rhine mange frolicking in the
running and then eventually they they
come across everything in this version
yeah so it becomes a beach and then they
comes out with the Rhine the rango the
who in those days was supposed to be a
big golden cloth but that all changed
and then of course there being brought
that back into the depths of the of the
Rhine and then the the
we had in those days we had vote on and
freaka sleeping and so it shows you a
bit how we how we played around with the
the actual set this is those are the
Giants and visiting because we kind of
tried to envision the Giants as two
giant hands coming to them and saying we
want to be paid so so we created these
giant hands and and their hands would
actually come in and kidnapped Freya
Freya and then after that they all
decided to go down to that's one of the
excerpts that we saw earlier on when it
becomes a giant staircase and decide to
go down to the tunable Hyneman
so of course you have to understand that
in those days we didn't have the vaguest
idea how we were going to do this we
just thought it would be an interesting
way of doing it so so then of course the
stead became became the the body of the
Dragon and essentially to see it this
way because it's quite naked because all
of this is is there's a lot of
interactive projections on this set but
this was like the bare bones of the the
whole the whole piece so I don't know if
we have the equivalent for Vancouver for
the others but I think that that's
pretty much it
are there any other well it may be just
to maybe give you an example of people
think I'm obsessed by big machines the
technology and all that I Joe I was
ended up working with these things but
I'm interested in low tech also and in
the very beginning of how you use
technology and I did this other opera
that's performing right now who was
beyond striking in Lyon but this week I
had the the nightingale
Stravinsky piece that I've been working
on and and we went to Vietnam to meet
with some Vietnamese water puppet
masters and the whole adventure this at
that time was to convince Opera House's
to empty the orchestra pits to put the
orchestra on stage to fill the orchestra
pit with water we have not done that and
the the actual seniors are waist-deep in
water and manipulate Vietnamese water
puppets and sing so maybe we have some
excerpts of of that we could show you
some other stuff that we've managed to
do and that's that's in the young right
now and it's been so in in this case
there's no projections there's no
engineering it's good old puppetry so we
have one of our cool puppetry involved
and this is actually a singer and the
chorus in the back all I have had to
learn how to manipulate taiwanese-style
puppets and so this is the piece we also
in the first part of that opera we also
worked with with very very very low tech
would we a lot of shadow play so maybe
we could show you some excerpts of the
first part
it's
a rare Stravinsky piece that's rarely
done and so there's a lot of hand
shadows and that's all done live onstage
and the audience gets to see both right
yeah absolutely because that's one of
the things that's I think is interesting
because yesterday I was part of a panel
about you know the world of illusions
and theatrical illusions and all that
and how one of the important things
about any kind of illusion or the use of
technologies is to actually have
confidence in the audience and their
intelligence and and actually show them
how things are made so people actually
see on the side all of the the hand
shadow and all that but of course the
the human eye is I was more interested
in fantasy so you eventually always look
for for the fantastical I did a show
once called the far side of the Moon
where I would kind of crawl on the floor
and I had a diagonal mirror in diagonal
and and you would get the illusion that
I was actually floating in space and of
course all of this was exposed the
audience could see me dragging myself on
the floor and they would see the effect
up in the mirror and even though they
would see how I do it they would always
be drawn by the effect so you know I was
I trust the the audience thirst for for
fantasy for poetry I think it's
marvelous the way you do combine sort of
low-tech and and and new I remember when
we were first talking about the ring
when I was pursuing you in London you
were doing an opera at the Royal Opera
House and or rather was it was after
that no you were doing the Andersen
project in London and I went to to watch
that was a wonderful one-man show like
other one-man shows you've done where
you play multiple characters and at one
point in the show you walk across the
stage as one character pass behind a
tree and then emerge on the other side
without breaking stride a dressed
completely differently as another
character there's this oral old tricks
of the trade member-sisters how did you
do that you said
so 18th century yeah it's actually about
a body double who's in in the hid
hitting in the tree in the tree you
actually and then I get to have a glass
of water hide for a while so they're all
they're all 19th century trick so I'm
very very I'm fascinated by that because
I think that we're in a world of
razzmatazz where we go to see 3d films
and and we watch television and
everything is into special effects and
all of that and very often you're a bit
a lien aided by all of that because you
always go how did they do that or how do
I do
I didn't understand how did he do that
but when in the theater you have the
possibility to actually show the strings
and show how it's done and give a chance
to the audience to use their
intelligence and their creativity and
and even the if they do find how you do
that yeah it's actually it's part of the
enjoyment of the whole thing when we
were talking about the ring at first I
remember you told me that you had
recently produced directed this new show
in Las Vegas when it when it opens at
your first or second search facility it
was the first show you specially called
cop which you suggested I might want to
go and check out because you told me
that I that you were going to use use
some of the technological ideas that you
developed for that in the service of of
the ring yeah
and that we would maybe maybe searches
slay shouldn't hear this but that
basically that we were going to Matt was
gonna be the beneficiary of this two
hundred million dollar twenty million
dollars per commercial project in Las
Vegas with which had the most amazing
effects obviously was a whole different
type of pop culture kind of event but
some of that technology in terms of
motion control and also interactive
interactivity was you you developed for
that show yeah and then used it now in
the ring act and actually I think in the
ring that detected the technology caught
up with the ideas which is kind of nice
but
the days of Cirque du Soleil there were
still very very bulky ideas and we and
we have some clips of you have got these
things maybe we could show with there's
the maybe the battle scene from cop from
Carlos which we could want to show that
where we try to use interactive video
for the first time and some of these
effects have found themselves in
so of course this looks like an overhead
shot of a battle but actually the whole
stage is vertical and they're actually
the things happening like this and so
usually how does it work well actually
they all have a harness and in their
hand they have a like a little little
button and that they actually pull
themselves up with this whole button
they push on the button and it
determines the speed at which they go up
and down and they so they're completely
independent of the but they're being
tracked by infrared sense and and then
for the what you see at the bottom that
the reflected all of that actually the
floor is is a sensitive floor that we
created that we invented at said
facility in 2003 I think wisdom so that
actually the the the wall in which
you're crashing to do this knows at what
speed you're coming in at what velocity
where you are so it so the video
actually reacts to you but I mean the
point I wanted to make with this excerpt
is that in the same thing for the for
the met is that all of these
technologies and these effects are there
to to be an echo of whatever the
performer does it the thing is not to
try to draw the attention these effects
don't have to draw the attentions to
themselves the idea is to try to magnify
whatever the performer is done the
velocity the the restraints and in in
the ring there's actually some some
great moments where what people see on
stage let's say it's a snowstorm or if
it's the wind that's in the trees all of
that is triggered by the sound that
comes from the pits and depending of the
sibilance the dynamics the velocity
whatever almost all the singers in the
ring or mic yeah not not to project
their voices into the theatre but to
help interact with the scenic effects
exactly so a lot of the the effects in
the ring are triggered by whatever the
performance is that night and so so of
course it's it's very tricky because you
have you always have to find the balance
and these things and you don't want
these affected
attention to themselves but of course
there's always that risk as people I've
never seen these things for the first
time they of course did I know last
night after the showing of the film at
Tribeca Jay hunter Morris who's this
miraculous discovery who was a cover for
the role of Zeke V possibly the hardest
tenor role in all of opera who stepped
in three days before the premiere
because the tenor who was supposed to
sing it couldn't wasn't well and
couldn't couldn't go on and Jay was
saying last night that he realized
because he was not familiar with the
said he had to get familiar very fast as
he was walking across the set in the
love duet with Brunhilde that takes
place at the end of Z Creed when he
discovers her and he's the hero who
unlocks her from this the sleep that
she's been sentenced to by her father he
realized that as he was walking leaves
were moving around the stage that were
were virtual interactive virtual leaves
and when he kicked one it actually moved
out of the way so he he was surprised he
was surprised as he has interacted
himself which also I think added to to
the wonder of his performance perhaps
well that's an interesting thing because
actually when you you do get to work
with the singers you and and some of
them of course are so preoccupied by
being heard and and and being you know
being there where they should be in the
score and being having eye contact with
the conductor and it's and also trying
to perform and being trying to be a good
listener with so there's an opera
singers mind is very very busy when he
sings and you know you try to say well
there's also all this world around you
that if ever you want to use it use it
so of course some singers and certainly
singers who sing the part for the first
time will be less generous with you but
on that aspect but people like print FL
and you know a senator who know that the
parts so well in order great today would
would climb on the set when it's not
time to climb on it and we do it so I
want to ride this I want to ride
would actually have fun with the
interaction in the video and all that so
I think the would time people will get
used to these new tools and these new
possibilities I think so right now I was
I wasn't really aware of this until I I
asked to see what you were doing at the
moment and in the world you have where's
the list here somewhere you actually
have this very moment for different
theatrical shows lip sync blue dragon
the Anderson project and a new show
called spades that I don't know about
which all of them are on tour in the
case of spades its opening in two weeks
you have the ring playing at the Met you
have nightingale Russell yo possibly
playing on the in the only if the
strikers come back to work you have to
Circus Circus la shows playing
simultaneously one is totem totem is
coming to Boston in June you have your
annual architectural visual project the
image mill so so under your hard to get
a hold of the the and then and then in
the any creative oven right now you have
like what do you have for another
another show I don't maybe you could
explain what spades is cuz I there's
another playing card show called
diamonds which is vehicle actually two
spaces part of the playing cards right
yes and and the tempest for the Memphis
a contemporary opera by Thomas Addis
that has already had two productions
since its supreme premiere in London
2004 five yeah and which you just were
we're working in workshop and we're
shopping last place Montreal yeah so so
this is quite a how do you do all these
things at once
well I'm very well organized very well
structured I have I'm a very very
chaotic person the way I work in a very
intuitive way so nobody used to
has has this many shows going on at the
same time well maybe I know Bob Wilson
probably has a few of those and I could
move at a slower pace okay yeah for some
reason as I get older I get more and
more stuff like no but the thing that
has to be known is that that I work in a
very very intuitive way I do I am I
don't work you know intellectual
organized way and all that but I have
tons of people around me to help me out
but it all takes place in you where
Robair works his headquarters which you
developed in the 90s I guess is this
converted firehouse barracks it was a
firehouse and the sleeping quarters yeah
cold-blood like like a damn ledge means
that I guess yeah where you all the
creative stuff happens yeah pretty much
is that that's where that's a starting
place oh so how many how many people do
you have in there doing it very well
maybe we have the cousin maybe twenty
some people who are permanent but
there's like hundreds of people that
work there a year and work also would we
co-produce an exchange with a lot of
people around the world and but I think
the the idea in the end I'm not saying
there's a secret recipe to be able to do
so many things at the same time it's
just that you have to be not only well
supported well structured well organized
by an extremely intelligent and
structured people around you but you you
also have to leave time for things to
happen so for example when we started
working on the ring you know five six
years ago and and you work on the ring
for maybe two weeks and then you you let
it you let it there for four months and
in the meantime you're working on a new
opera or on another show on a creation
or on the circus show and they also go
through the same kind of process so
after a while you can actually manage a
lot of things at the same time a dam
they kind of cook and it's it's slow
food it's and so I'm very privileged not
because I'm in a position where I I
never say yes to a project that's going
to happen this summer or in the fall I I
say okay in what year and how can we
space out the the development phases of
dam projects and I think that's part of
the part of the secret because a lot of
stuff happens in the back of your head
that you don't know about between these
sessions
you work on that say we'd rehearse for
three weeks on a project and then
everybody disappears for four months and
during that four months you're not
thinking of the project but something in
the back of your head your subconscious
actually men's stuff find solutions that
are good and bad good for the creative
absolutely yeah and in all of these
projects inform each other so sometimes
the the answer to a problem on one
project will be found in the other
project and all that so that's also a
very intricate system and yeah and you
can't command that that happens it just
happens that way
the do you want to are there any other
examples of current stuff that you I
don't know anything you'd like to talk
to that how about the image mill young
which is this annual visual event that
started a couple years ago it's in
Quebec City yeah and at this place that
you were mentioning earlier on the the
chasm which is our the fire hall or
studio or our lab in Quebec City where
we develop most of our things we have a
lot of interesting creative minds that
gravitate around us it feels that times
a bit like MIT and that's why I feel I
feel a bit at home here in that sense we
have some really interesting minds and
and so the image mill was created during
the the 2008 celebrations of the 400th
anniversary of Quebec City so I had been
commissioned to do some kind of event
and we chose to do the world's largest
architectural projection it's actually
0.6 kilometers long it's in the Guinness
Book of Records yeah well if I'm gonna
brag about something of it
and and well maybe we could show some
images as we're speaking it just to give
you an idea of the scope of it or the
and what it is here you see it sits in
the the harbor in Quebec City and those
are 86 grain silos the building that you
see there is this huge a Jewish thing
that's actually blocking the view from
the river in Quebec City so we decided
to transform it into some kind of
projection surface and we managed with
time to add 3d effects and all that so
this is a result of projections that we
do we pretend that the silos actually
reveal their contents and then it's it's
quite a big so this is in the context of
the city you see how big it is and so
it's seen from every point in the city
and people gather in in in the in the
harbor to see it but also it's seen from
hotel rooms and it's a soundtrack is is
on a radio channel that people can so
it's quite a big event people come by
boat there's also people that visit the
the river during the daytime and then
they all kind of Park their their boats
and the and the harbour and come to see
and it's basically what it does is the
history of Quebec City which is the the
oldest city in North America in fact in
the world so it's the story of for four
different centuries of the for centuries
and what they're about and a lot of
archives and how many projectors you
it's done with twenty in fact it's
twenty five high-definition projectors
but there's probably 28 because there's
always one that goes wrong it's always
you know about that is always something
that goes wrong in these big things and
it's all synchronized by the same
computer so it's a big team that works
on that every year and it's it was quite
an event in this part of the signature
of the city now that's fantastic
the of course that's that's the the one
the debt the downside of using all this
technology is that when things do go
wrong yeah you seems you feel a little
bit helpless
yeah of course we've had
I mean is it but but I mean but that's
okay that's part of the sport of theater
that's always what I say I mean just
because we got accustomed to the
guillotine of the opening night of a
movie you can't change a movie the
movies out is there just we can't do
anything but theater it's a living
animal and it changes and of course and
what's it you know we use the ring has
changed the entire culture and
atmosphere of the Met for in terms of
inside the man he's the stage crew we
have we have 200 stage hands who work at
the Met in order to move the scenery in
and out of the band and to operate shows
we're a repertory theatre with seven
shows a week two different operas on
Saturday matinee and evening performance
and a stage that is in constant use
where we have a rehearsal in the daytime
today for example we were rehearsing a
revival of Billy Budd and now right at
this moment the crew was frantically
making sure that all the connections in
the machine are ready for the prince a
night's performance of Reingold but the
what's different about about the ring in
terms of the the culture of the of the
Met and the way they were the way the
crew works is that for the first time
they've never had to interact with
scenery like that because as
computerized and advanced as as the ring
is the ultimately what it as you evolve
the designs it came down to stage hands
also manipulating the planks and holding
the planks and having to and a lot of
the stage lifts of the met being used to
introduce various scenic elements so
it's a its interactive between people
and the machinery and it's become also a
bit puppet like in a certain way it's
puppetry and and and I have to say that
the crew at the Met have been so proud
of the whole project and they love it
and they've invested themselves so much
into this and they're so proud of the
whole production and and they've put so
much creative energy and
if they've never been so stimulated I
mean cuz every stagehand gets to you
know really be involved absolutely
in a way they normally wouldn't be yeah
the you know I thought it would be
interesting perhaps to talk a little bit
once you said to me I remember some
months ago that you that you I don't
know if you were actually a busker but
you said that that you grew up with sort
of this uniquely gifted group of Quebec
waz citizens wolf who sort of come from
the same generation including the
keithandbeth to deliver liberty is a
founder of circus Olay so is that how
did you begin I mean well actually I I
studied at the conservatory to become an
actor but it's in Canada Inc in Quebec
City and so when I came out of the
conservatory I didn't think I'd have a
career as a as an actor because I didn't
have any casting for anything you know
and in those days it was very very kind
of flower power and we're very much into
collective writing and doing political
theater and all that so I was pretty
much doing that kind of kind of thing we
would do stuff and we'd play in the
street and we'd make the money that
people would give us and it wasn't very
influenced by the Bread and Puppet and
the living theater and whatever movement
was going on here in the United States
and never really thought that I'd have a
career as a as an actor or a director
and you know just always did these small
little troops and didn't have any big
ambitions and eventually it kind of
caught on and we started touring the
world and people start to be very
interested in you know we're touring on
your own or with with with the group
with the company and and for some reason
I never work moved then interested and
people were identified ourselves to what
we were doing and and suddenly we
started co-producing with people from
all over the world and and we became you
know very much in demand and and but I
always remembered that when I was in the
conservatory I was interested in acting
and all that but I spent way too much
time with the people doing production I
was very interested in
sound editing and lighting design and
all these other things and I'd always
get flack um my teachers would say
you're spending way too much time on
these things and you should be working
more on your acting and all that so it
so from the very very beginning I've
always had a finger in every pie and and
and I never thought that that would
actually be a quality it's always been
seen as a as a flaw and so what time you
do so it creates a kind of conscience of
what what theatre is and how and you
have to be I mean if you want theater to
survive you have to be interested in all
these things you've not only worked as
an actor you've worked as a dancer
recently recently at age 50 at age 50
civilian who's who's an amazing dancer
who's a star dancer showed up at a
performance of the Anderson project in
Australia and said the world we'd like
I'd like to work with you and I said
fine and but I thought she wanted me to
direct her or to help her being because
I know she wanted to maybe find a way to
become an actress so she ate so so I
said well fine and and we had a few
meetings and all that at one point I
said you know so yeah I'm not sure that
I'm the right person to work with you
because I'm not a choreographer and I'm
not sure I understand very well I said I
don't want you to choreograph from you
to direct me I want to dance with you
and with vgm you didn't have to say yes
well no but this vgm comes up two inches
I want to dance with you you know you
have to you have to say yes so I was at
least 35 pounds larger bigger heavier
whatever you say and I said my god this
is this is suicidal so why not and and
and we got together and developed this
extraordinary story about Chevalley do
when was it Salameh difficult to explain
in its classical dance modern dance
theater influenced by a lot of martial
arts and all these things and a year
later I was I was dancing look I was
dancing at Sadler's Wells and we just
recently came back from
and it's a good way to keep you keep
your weight - well that's the problem is
that you know I'm I'm in a crime a
squeeze box I'm gonna cordial that's
just that every time we do the show I
have to lose a lot of weight to fit in
my Alexander McQueen tights and after
that when I when I when the show is off
and there's a six months period of
different between shows I just got this
this thing so but it's it's
extraordinary and and it's great because
you think you know and of course it'll
be now it isn't it is and maybe I don't
know exactly what a chi is but she's you
know she's she's not in her 20s anymore
and and and she still works and she
still is an amazing an amazing artist
and and and so it kind of was a good
example thing to say well you know
retirements not a not an option I think
you could always learn at any age and
and I like being surprised in my career
by or things like that you know suddenly
somebody shows up in your dressing room
and says I wanna dance with you I need
you and you're 50 and you're out of
breath and you you want to die and you
have to so it's I mean it's I like
life's life-changing Suzanne the same
thing happened when Hugh and you showed
up I've Covent Garden and said you want
to do the ring and I went oh my god and
your world yeah why not somebody offers
you two to climb Mount Everest you have
to do it you know and so so I know I
like I like that and I'm afraid somebody
tonight it's got to come up to me and
suggest something I don't know but I
don't know it's the kind of thing it's
the kind of accidents you'd like to bump
into the kind of thing that that's cool
so what are some of the future future of
Mount Everest for you I know you have
this extraordinary theater project
you're building a theater right yeah
we're building to talk about that yeah
because we have the Kazon in Quebec City
but we just have we just received part
of the funding to actually build a new
room in Quebec City or not an actual
theater where we let's actually design
for our work and will we also be
presenting maybe small operas circus
shows it's gonna be it's gonna place
it's called the diamond
and the reason why it's called the
diamond because a diamond has Multi
multi faceted like our work but also
because Quebec City is built on Cape
Diamond because the French thought that
there was a lot of that's why they
settled there they saw this diamond this
did this shiny stuff of course it's not
diamonds at all and and also because
when I opened that first Center 20-some
years ago
Bob Wilson was elegant enough to send me
a video message where he said our cities
need centers a diamond in an apple which
is a very Bob Wilson to say a diamond
and then I believe of course and so he's
congratulations to Roberto Pasha Center
in LA and I said well this is a nice
image of diamond in an apple and and
it's true I mean I think that our
cultural centers whether it's the
Lincoln Center or the Met or whatever
this this place here has to be that's
what we have to have to be like a
shining jewel and and with all of the
alchemic notions of what what a jewel is
can you describe some of these shows
that you have in the works right now
there's a lot of them but maybe I
described one because it's a variant but
the one about the the playing card yeah
and also has to do with what I did here
this weekend at MIT is that part of the
MIT events because I was getting a
workshop with some of the - - some of
the students here about this theme of
playing cards and and so after doing the
ring in four-part epic I'm doing yet
another four-part epic going on playing
cards and of course the first part is
called spades the second is hearts the
third one is diamonds and the last one
is clubs and it's a very very very long
project it's going to be 12 hours of
theater eventually and all that but
we're premiering in Madrid in two weeks
from now spades and it's
so it's just a group of people that got
together and started writing all these
extraordinary stories about playing
cards which is a very very inspiring
object or sensitive resource and so to
collect you a collector it's a
collective effort so that's that's
pretty much what I'll be doing when when
I ironed off tomorrow we're going to
Madrid tomorrow well I mean we're going
to Quebec City for a but we've to sort
out what we're gonna be doing in Madrid
two weeks from now but it's a three-hour
show and and it's quite extraordinary
because it's set in Las Vegas the the
weekend when Celine Dion's show
premiered at that there was in like
again that in 2002 or 2003 and it's that
weekend where she premiered her show at
Caesar's Palace and it's the same
weekend when the the Allies started to
bomb Baghdad so it's about two deserts
and about you know two separate a set of
events that are interconnected and so
yeah so it's a crazy project sounds
great we have a new production of
Rigoletto next season set in Las Vegas
oh really fast see there's rapine 19
1961
been there done that bought the t-shirt
you're not you're not directing it
should we ask from the audience if they
have any questions yes I think I think
that we proposed some is standing by for
you that will be brought in and Phillip
is going there they are come to our
moderating age
that is if there are if there are any
questions thank you very much questions
and in the MIT tradition if you just you
know state your name and very briefly
who you are what you are
hello my name is Rhiannon I'm a member
of Homo sapiens sapiens human first I
just want to say Monsieur Lapage you're
like a rock star to me my kind of people
I'm like your groupie right now so yeah
you're my Elvis um thank you very much
no yeah no hip Wiggles necessary don't
worry my question has to do with people
like me I just graduated from college
with a degree in music and technology
and theaters my life I'm part of elfs I
Omega I I love being on stage off stage
backstage building the stage whatever
stage but the problem is I just
graduated college with the music and
Technology degree I don't have any money
I don't have any time I'm trying to work
trying to get a house real life is scary
so my question to you before I can win
the McDermott award and do the Ring
cycle what's what what do I do I'm kind
of
I'm kind of lost here I'm wondering I
don't have the tools I don't have tools
I don't have a workshop I don't have the
contacts and I don't have the money to
get any of it um what's my first step
well III I have to admit that the the
funding arts funding here in this
country is still a big mystery to me I
don't really know how it works I know
there's some very generous people around
who could help you out but I know also
that it's not necessarily a priority for
for governments or for so that I know
that in Canada we do we do have that
great advantage that we have subsidies
and but this being said my company is
not sub I don't get that much money from
the government's we get maybe twelve
percent of our of the money that we we
generate is because we we actually
understood very early in the process
that we had to go elsewhere to find it
that we we traveled and we started doing
doing adventures with people were in and
there are people who are ready to risk
years in advance to work with you
they'll give you the money upfront say
well when you're ready when the work is
ready so sometimes when we can't find
the solutions in our own surroundings we
have to kind of move around and maybe
you have to emigrate to Canada or or
embark on any kind of venture with
people abroad and eventually be
recognized in as an artist so there are
there are theater programs in companies
in this in this country that have
apprentice programs and if that's you
know you're different there are
different ways of getting your foot in
the door thank you very much please yeah
hi my name's my name is Matt Kray I
actually teach acting and directing here
at Northeastern University I also have a
Canadian passport so it's nice to see a
familiar face I'm really interested in
some of some nuts and bolts things the
theatre kind of traditional timeline is
to add tech at the end and so many of
your pieces over the years both in
theatre and also in Opera integrate
technology so beautifully in the
storytelling
I'm curious at what point did they begin
to enter into the process with the
performers how they respond to it and
how
that processes to you well very often
it's on from day one I know that beresch
at the end of his life Podesta was
working on this idea that everybody has
to work as if everybody has to be in the
rehearsal room on day one even if they
don't have much to do they should be
there and of course that's a very
expensive process but there's people who
are ready to do that for very cheap and
I know that for example when I did the
far side of the Moon was a one-man show
but the room was crowded with people
with technicians and all that didn't
happen didn't know really what they did
they were what the use of them was there
but they're just there and they
participate in the conversations and all
that and eventually people do drawings
and and very very early on in the
process they they suggest stuff and you
start and certainly in this day and age
where everybody has a power book and
goes on the web and I would do an improv
and somebody some lighting designer or a
technician would say you know that the
guy you were quoting what actually the
quote is this and then there's this
whole thing that happens so now I think
we have the tools very accessible and
cheap tools for to invite a lot of
people in in the rehearsal woman and and
to not 2d sacral eyes the the rehearsal
room that's usually reserved to the
director and the actor but to because my
work is also a writing process I think
that if everybody there has their say's
chances are their technologies or their
craft will be better integrated will be
will seem more essential to the work
because it's informed from day one so
what happens is that you you you you
destroy all of the hierarchy the useless
hierarchy of the writer and then the
director and then the the slave actors
and then after that and then we bring in
the technicians and that that it's it's
like that because up for just for
practical reasons or economical reasons
so if you could find a way to make it
current economically to have people from
day one everybody there in the room and
everybody knows what the what the what
the project is about I think of course
an opera that's not possible
well it wasn't part when we did the ring
because we when we rehearsed in backend
close to Montreal I'm saying with the
sing at extremes of singers we didn't
have the singers we do we do part of the
crew and we
have a lot of people in that room yes
sir hi I'm David filling ham
I graduated from Brandeis University in
1981 with a music degree and I went to
the old met 62 to 70 and it feels to me
that a lot of the great set designers
like Zeffirelli etc are being very much
ignored these days
I appreciate what you do very much I'm
not in any way suggesting otherwise I
was with Bread and Puppet Theatre from
70 to 76 and we come from the same world
but it seems to me that a lot of art is
mediated through electronics these days
rather than the beauty of the art itself
and and certainly the mechanical
brilliance of Zeffirelli and people like
that make some what we do look excuse me
for saying it this way but pedestrian
could you talk a little bit about art
and design as opposed to technology and
design please yeah well I would just
like to say since you mentioned the word
Zeffirelli I feel that's partly my
territory so you know Zeffirelli is in
his 80s now and you know in his time he
was a great theatrical innovator and he
did wonderful productions but you know
his time was then all art forms need to
advance through the current generations
of master directors and designers and
certainly as far as the Met is concerned
we do not ask for the meant to be
overrun with technology what we ask is
great storytelling directors to create
their best work at the Met with the
tools that they wish to bring
as part of that as part of that process
so there are directors who in at the met
this past season for example we had
seven new productions David McVicker was
a very accomplished stage director
directed a new production of Anna Bolena
which has there's nothing there are no
projections it's all just old-fashioned
scenery but presented and with a modern
aesthetic all the scene changes to take
place in front of the audience we don't
bring in the heavy curtain in between
each scene you know there maleeh what
makes theatre and opera interesting
today is the the wealth of imagination
that comes from different directors who
who who work in in in creating new work
so you know everything move has to move
forward what Zeffirelli did in the 70's
and 60s was terrific then but it's not
so terrific now you know it's not what's
not interesting I think for an audience
today is to see every inch of the of the
Met proscenium stuffed with scenery
sometimes you know in some of these
older productions the scenery may look
interesting but you have no idea who's
singing so what we're trying to do is
bring in directors who are trying you
know who are in touch with with and who
are creating the sensibilities and
sensitivities and leading audiences
today and and and ultimately with the
goal of pleasing them well something
okay cuz think is it further yeah I
should say it but it's just that in the
60s we had no confusion about who was
singing and what the sets were well well
something those if you come to see The
Tempest for example that we're producing
this year it is without very very very
it's very little technology involved and
we never had this kind of conversation
about technology on the tempest it's
actually more of an a master's if really
in a certain way where you would happen
it's a question of context there's
certain certain pieces or certain
artistic adventures do sometimes ask for
a new vocabulary so and that sometimes
involves technology and of course
because we are we are
heavily using excerpts of context where
we did experiment a lot with
technologies of course that's part of
our conversation but there's many many
many other context is and projects that
we have that have nothing to do with
that and and where we do have an
appreciation of and even we even do an
homage to the craft of people like
Zeffirelli or early stage designers who
were amazingly amazing painters amazing
image makers I think it's important that
directors have the ability to draw upon
what is available today to to pursue
their craft you know movies today
obviously don't looks like they did 30
years ago or 40 years ago when Steven
Spielberg started harnessing special
effects in on behalf of what of ET or
some of the wonderful films that he made
those films couldn't have been possible
10 or 20 years earlier with the result
that there was a whole debate also in
did black and white the amazing black
and white days of movies it was just so
fantastic and how people even Cocteau
swore that he'd never do a color movie
because when color invaded said well you
know and then it's it's all about
something that's not about really and
they eventually gave in at the end of
his life and did a color movie it's it's
I was I think that the when when new
tools come in and new paintbrushes come
in and new colors come in
we're always wary of them and always
afraid of them because we don't know
them and fear is always the cause of it
always comes from ignorance and because
we don't know about something we we fear
it anyway and and and but then these
things kind of get get introduced and to
into the whole array of possibilities
and so when you happen to be at the
cutting edge of these things of course
you're more vulnerable to the criticism
and and then if you you're using
technologies that are kind of accepted
or taken for granted
we actually have time for one more
question with apology but our guests
have other obligations so please you
would
I'm a mechanical engineer here and I
went to see go throw down room with the
MIT art scholars and it was really
magical and I think you already answered
my question so I might let somebody else
go but I wanted to ask whether you said
that people will become accustomed to
the technology and used to seeing it so
whether you thought that would detract
from the magic or detract from peace
know that I think it's a question of you
know when Eisenstein first presented the
career as a Potemkin
actually there's people who recount that
in that first projection some people hid
behind their seats because they thought
the boat was going to come through the
screen and and were distracted by a lot
of these things and and the first time
footlights electrical footlights were
people actually wrote about how
electricity should not be permitted in a
theater because the the the organic
essence of the candles and all that and
and if you have if if you see too much
the actors you won't listen to them as
much and what's important in theater is
a text so yeah and all these things were
all these comes and eventually people
see the advantage of seeing the actors
better as their you know and that's what
I mean so that's what I'm not I'm not
offended and I mean I agree does there's
a lot of dangers and flaws and we might
have failed at times and maybe it may be
in the case of the ring they it was a
bit overwhelming and whatever but still
there are some magical moments where a
more custom audience to these kind of
devices we're actually looking at
listening to the singer while others
were going what is this anniversary or
so of course you know and that's fine
and that's part of the whole process and
that's why I'm saying you know in two
three ten years that'll be part of what
people are used to and that's also
something I have think it's an important
question because it has to do with
knowing who what the audience knows
about storytelling and 25-30 years ago
the audiences didn't know much about
jump cuts and
flash-forwards and all of this
vocabulary that television and rock
videos and whatever movies that people
will see now people have a vocabulary
they're very educated people even people
who've never been to school go listen to
stories go to movies and all that and
there's this whole thing that's
developed with time and you have to take
that into account when you you try to
convey a story today if you don't do
that and you try to respect a tradition
and all of that people are at the end of
the play before you are so you really
have to try to understand where people
are you know in how do you understand
the story and if they're ready to follow
you in any new way of saying things in
just you've raised our sights you've
raised our spirits you've done just I
think what we hoped would happen with
robear's residency here in celebrating
the McDermott Award and so we
congratulate you
MIT thanks you I hope you will come back
and Peter you're always welcome back too
so thank you everyone